[Music]
okay guys if you would see this sign in
this aisle what would your reaction be
help us build safer communities report
shoplifting to a member of I'm not a
narc you a monarch that's mine that's my
reaction I didn't that would make me
want to steal I'd be like wow this place
is really insane I'll be like somebody's
stealing tampon yeah
same here does you only see it in
California you can see up to $700 with
the [ __ ] and they really want 700 now
yeah I'll be 500 because anything over
500 was considered grand theft really
they changed it mmm seven seven Hondo
cuz if you let me know what your buttons
are I need to push them don't tell me
your buttons cuz I'm not aw just start
stealing [ __ ]
do you ever steal these days just for
the fun of it not anymore just checking
man one time Chea needed something like
I think she was feeling like sick or
something right before a flight and she
needed something and like but our flight
was boarding and the line to check out a
little at the little like gift shop was
so long Hudson's yeah yeah oh yeah
whatever the [ __ ] right yeah for some
reason this the CNBC shop I'm like what
though yeah so I'm like so I saw like
let's say it was like I don't know nasal
spray or some [ __ ] I was like gotta do
it for your wife from your wyman let
probably the last thing I stolen like
the past like 10 years premiere pocket I
was like get out of there then walked
out like that's like maybe it's like
here you go put this tuck this away I
just I could go to jail right now I did
this for you they're gonna do some
bosses [ __ ] like you get it and you put
a hundred dollar bill I can't wait oh no
just stolen no meanwhile the the CNBC
shop guy he's like he's like okay
everything's going be booked yes yes oh
no the nails but oh no I can't afford no
I can't make rent I'm not a business he
gets fired
yeah he's fire dude now he's and I was
in the methadone clinic cuz of you lost
his kids yeah I hope it's for my wife
well so he lost his whole family was the
nasal spray worth it
yes okay so this sign that you guys saw
it
at a Tesco which is a British grocery
chain I've seen that Oh so what's happen
packs yes and so someone at Tesco and
then they took a photo and then they
send it to a friend who then sent it to
whatever the point is and when it got on
Twitter viral is it because it's because
it's in front of women's products and so
only women's would see stealing you're
not far off
yes the fact that it is you know for
menstrual sanitary products where you
know if someone is in a position where
they need to steal this which should be
like a basic human thing whatever that's
kind of [ __ ] up so what stealing is
[ __ ] up though no no for sure it's
[ __ ] up but it's just like she's just
saying the situation of someone to have
that steal at his [ __ ] you're saying
that she's equally put signs in front of
everything that's what I was know I used
to plan from the cantaloupes and stuff
too right so they're saying it's like
it's like what like women shouldn't even
have to pay for this [ __ ] to the
cantaloupe feet we should have to pay
for cantaloupes we should all have
fruits for free yes I'm hungry and I'm
like Aladdin and I want to steal a nap
Oh what is that what does that mean well
you get your hands chopped off it means
you're [ __ ] up yeah but [ __ ] I should
I say terrific rat riffraff yeah human
right a basic human right if I got a key
I think so I think your toilet paper and
I'd ran up to a pepper on my house
mm-hmm
it's a basic human need it's a basic
human need to essaouira starburst or not
really you could just rinse your ass huh
say you think the tampon should be 100
percent free
I'm just reporting this I say yes you're
the messenger okay I'm reporting it
right how percent free yes but what if
what if it's if it's free but it's not
like the luxurious of course it's not
gonna be my so bad I kind of hesitated
because I'm like I know we're gonna get
the cardboard [ __ ] cuz you don't in perl
the next level see ya they just have the
government [ __ ] in all the bathrooms
well at least they have that [ __ ] and
then you go go and in that a punk comes
out well if it's at least available that
should see the bare [ __ ] minimum so
should we go to Tampax with guns and be
like you'll give us us Geoffrey
shouldn't be jam-packed or they could
get
oh it's bran should we go - which brand
name one no no baby cats thank you going
to coat tents with you what is that
Gatling gun tommy gun yes it's a ok
you'll give us a sample see human right
banana - we're like we should all have
bananas for free listen we just went to
play text so don't even give us a [ __ ]
about dying it's not fair ya know cuz I
mean they give government government
assistance to many other places and I
can't my brain stopped working the point
is be more pointing out that they give
out condoms for free why can't they give
out sanitary products very I mean who
gives out condoms for free the clinic
Planned Parenthood does yeah those guys
are funded by private but mostly by
private industry and also guess what
someone's paying for it is what they're
saying yeah but someone's paying for it
that's ok that's it that's the thing is
you can't go into a store where it's
someone's livelihood and be like give me
all your products for free because it's
right that's why they're saying no I
don't know if that's what the article
saying well I'm just [ __ ] with the
premise I mean yeah kind of cuz I think
like yeah I think like based off that
picture people are drawing conclusions
and also zoom out zoom in/out zooming
out check it for zooming that far out
they were like well someone needs to pay
for don't no that's not what I was
taking from the circus is one I was
listening to her say the story and where
my mind was going was like if someone is
in such a bad position or a woman isn't
such a bad place that she has to steal
from this report it to the person so
that maybe we can donate something to
her or help her in some way that's right
jewel yeah not a systemic problem no but
I was just kind of drawing a different
Carmel woman are you'll see I'm going to
barbell I'm just doing a weight so that
I can go do weights at home but that's
not human basically like me how it is to
be healthy it is no it's not argue it's
not a preventative measure for my health
but you can walk and that's free and
that's available to you yeah but walking
isn't as effective as lifting weights I
hurt you but no it is it's so very
healthy so I just think it's very well
told you do you know a girl of some sort
me Dido goober actually
[Laughter]
yeah I mean that is a sanitary products
it's still the same thing it is you
could do an emergency wrap up with
toilet paper and put that you'll be tuna
patties oh wait are you man splitting us
bro I'm just saying what do they do back
in a day before they had it's not a
bumper cats an actual rag they had a rag
or they had [ __ ] red tents and [ __ ]
where the woman has to stay there for an
entire week bleeding is it hey they're a
group I worked pretty long I'm not even
mansplaining with the way the rat rag
was right what pretty good created those
those underwear that now absorbed me I
mean that's kind of like a more improved
way anyway okay so someone else
responded they said shoplifting isn't
the problem it's the fact that sanitary
products aren't free and accessible to
those who men straight and then also
they were saying that's another one well
see that's the thing it's only like in
this photo it's only a one ninety yeah
that's really expensive like British
yeah you know why but because of some
[ __ ] out there was like I'm gonna get
[ __ ] rich selling tampons and then
somebody else is like yo I'm gonna get
rich selling tampons and they went into
competition with each other and they're
like I'm gonna drop my prices down I'm
gonna drive my presto and then that's
why this [ __ ] that [ __ ] cheat so what
they're arguing for is against why it's
[ __ ] cheap that's what's [ __ ] nuts
you want to drive prices up then just
have one person or one supplier hose
down never gonna happen really shitty
quality - it's gonna burn your [ __ ] in
half Oh also are these signs just
everywhere in the store and the good
question sign just happened to be in
front right so they don't confirm that
in this article that I came across but I
assume that they do have it so this was
just an unfortunate placement like help
you hold everybody [ __ ] getting mad
these days okay but they also said they
said Tesco responded with we know that
the cost of buying essential sanitary
products can be a real struggle for some
which is why we were the first retailer
to cover the cost of the tampon tax aka
double kink tax to make these items more
affordable we want everyone to feel
welcome in our stores and we are very
sorry for any offence caused so they're
just saying like this was just in an
unfortunate
when did products become a human right
it's I mean right that's right that's my
whole because right because I feel like
it if you want to make things cheaper
get rid of the [ __ ] California state
sales tax on certain items it's not
explicit right it's almost I think it's
ten percent so maybe this don't tax that
would make that [ __ ] cheaper right there
boom immediately pink tax bro it's more
of a maroon text oh no maybe that's more
like a like a brown music why depends
what day and then how long it's been
around yeah yeah I could just be talking
about the inside of the [ __ ] I was
gonna say right like women can't help
that they have their period so likewise
you have to pay for it but then to your
point [ __ ] waters expensive too
you know I'm saying like bottles of
water everybody needs to drink water
you do it like you know in in the u.s.
at least they do have water filtration
systems where we can consume the water
that comes out of the faucet so that is
like water is being provided as a basic
need well here's another argument that
we pay for it though the most highly
stolen things is baby formula right
shouldn't all babies eat you know I mean
so I think it's just people are just
having these emotional arguments for
things but products someone needs to
make them someone needs to pay for them
like that's just the way it is I like
that idea we're moving the text but then
somebody would counterpoint you and the
real quick I'm just saying how open I
end all this [ __ ] mmm like I would
counter for you with like what TIFF just
said about the water supply well we use
tax money to pay for the water supply so
not so but my whole point is it's like
take our income taxes use that [ __ ]
instead of [ __ ] doing all stupid dumb
[ __ ] yeah and then like yeah maybe
certain items are not sales tax and that
would be a 10% like produce I don't
think we pay tax on produce no we don't
yeah you know and it's like you don't
yes it's [ __ ] up if Lego blamed
supermarkets or the private companies
for this stuff right if you're like a
like a homeless lady and you and you
don't have time off like yeah that's
definitely [ __ ] up right cuz it's like
you're gonna be bleeding regardless of
everything you don't say it there's no
like woman's like community centers or
whatever they give away oh I'm sure they
do I knew for a fact if you go to any
student health center in college he does
walk in and they'll give you a bag of
[ __ ] condoms for free and every color
my Parenthood or whatever you walk and
you say I need some condoms it was
always the condoms the one condoms with
like it was a circle wrapping and not
like not direct oh yeah that's why I
keep that me in a direct that's why I
can't see that's why I can't stand when
some people are like hey I think that
this is [ __ ] up
capitalism hell yes and then they're
like yo Planned Parenthood hell no I'm
like wait so this is one of the great
things that capitalism is allowed to
provide is that we can get cheap
products but then also an institution
like Planned Parenthood could exist
because of private donations that will
do so like what the [ __ ] is your problem
playing hip parenting like well I just
don't want to be government funded
because it's mostly funded by
individuals anyway but I'm like okay
fine but at least it exists isn't that a
good thing when they're like well no I'm
happy they carried my chlamydia and gave
me a bunch of condoms I love Planned
Parenthood try to do the tight yeah
[Music]